hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
june 3rd 2021 what's going on how
are you what's going on everybody i hope
you're doing well
in all of that [ __ ] um
i am not doing well i'm doing well
mentally by [ __ ]
i'm out of shape i'm out of shape and it
[ __ ]
stops right now
it was a birthday party last night right
and i was at it and my wife's like
oh my god this this light in the car is
great for us
you know let's take a picture took a
picture and my [ __ ] stomach was just
sitting in my lap well you know
like a big fat [ __ ] toad i've had it
so
you know this is just just this time of
year where there's just a bunch of
friends and everybody
have like [ __ ] birthdays and i have a
birthday
so it's just like every other day i'm
having a piece of cake and i'm just
[ __ ]
uh too old to do it
it's just it's just such a crime how
hard you have to [ __ ] work
to lose weight versus how quickly you
can put it on
i mean to do it right to keep it off if
you wanted to drop 20 pounds
say whatever a pound a week two pounds a
week you're talking anywhere from three
to six [ __ ] months
dude you could put 20 [ __ ] pounds on
on a vacation
[Music]
okay you know i heard oh i'm gonna i'm
gonna enjoy myself when i'm out everyone
what what's vacation for
right the whole vacation your [ __ ]
belt keeps sliding over another notch
you know and you got three days left and
you just disgusted with yourself you
decide to go for a walk
right and those [ __ ] seagulls are
hovering over you as you go down the
boardwalk because they're like look at
this fat bastard
if he doesn't have food now he's gonna
have some sod
right i think i think we got ourselves a
good league
glenn gary glenn ross let's par let's
follow this [ __ ] pasty fat so he's
not gonna be in the sun long
um by the way i [ __ ] hate seagulls
man [ __ ] aggressive [ __ ]
coming down on old ladies french fries
on the boardwalk
right i thought this i thought this
country was against that type of
behavior
terrorism you know is it because they're
white birds they can get away with it oh
geez he's becoming too woke
um
i saw somewhere i think it was jersey
they actually brought some [ __ ]
falcons in you know a couple of bob
proberts rest his soul
came in there to [ __ ] you know settle
things down a little bit
these things were coming in what
seagulls had at the beach in jersey
was what a certain group of people have
had for too [ __ ] long
is uh unchecked power
and i don't give a [ __ ] if it's a human
being or a bird
nobody can handle unchecked power
it's very few
you're gonna do something
it's gonna be too easy right these
[ __ ] birds right they got their
[ __ ] infinity pools
they got their [ __ ] right they can
just [ __ ] bang another seagull they
don't have to look over their shoulder
so what does jersey do
they bring it they just brought a couple
of falcons in
and these [ __ ] seagulls all started
screaming like little [ __ ]
warning each other oh [ __ ]
there's a falcon around it's gonna do to
us
what the [ __ ] we've been doing to other
people it was a bird of color
holy [ __ ]
the big fear of these white birds is
another [ __ ] bird's gonna come in and
do to them what they've been doing to
others oh look at there it is everybody
wrap it up in a bow i've been watching
these [ __ ] seagulls right and they
[ __ ]
over in europe there's one there's an
island and there's all of these [ __ ]
rabbits and these goddamn seagulls if
they can catch one
they swing it around by its neck and
then they just swallow it whole
the thankless life of a rabbit
or just pray
you are pray why do they call it pray is
it p-r-a-y no p-r-e-y
that your only hope is that it is just
it's gonna happen and your only hope is
that it's not gonna be you
that's like that giant fat [ __ ]
lizard i saw out here
big fat liz i mean this thing little
gecko right
it's the biggest gecko i've ever seen i
put it on my instagram page right
i think i can post about that not
getting in trouble
you know is this really the time for a
white man to be telling this lizard
story
ah the lizard was in my backyard but why
is it your backyard
isn't it really native americans
backyard
well where do you live that's not part
of the narrative where i live is not
part of the narrative
um anyway uh
this [ __ ] lizard was so goddamn big i
like took a step i opened my
door and it was sitting right there
um this thing wasn't fat
it was [ __ ] jacked and i was just
looking marveled at this thing
like how did you as prey
get this [ __ ] old and this goddamn
big
and i actually read because their food
supply is dwindling they start to eat
each other eating
each other
so anyway kind of uh you know
i filmed the thing and i left it alone
and the next day you know i was cleaning
up my garage and i picked up this ladder
that i had on the floor and the other
thing was
sitting there again showing it to my
daughter
she was like whoa that's a really big
one
her new thing is really that's my
favorite thing
all right buddy i i can't take you to
the park today but tomorrow after school
take you to the park she just goes
really
um yeah she's hilarious she told me
yesterday uh two days ago she told me uh
you broke my heart
i was like oh my god we were playing
this board game
and she just was i don't know she was
tired or whatever
she was throwing the pieces and i'd keep
picking him up and i was like
sweetheart stop throwing the pieces all
right
and then she'd be like you're not being
nice to me and i'm like i'm not the one
throwing the pieces around the room
all right stop doing that you do that
again the game's over right so we're
playing and playing and playing
and at one point she just i don't know
what
she started acting like joe pesci in
that blackjack
scene in casino right minus aldi carson
right she just
cleared the table of the stuff and i
didn't say anything
i just picked up the pieces i started
putting them in the bag
she clocked what i was doing she's like
dad what are you doing i was like the
game's over
and then she just burst it into tears no
crying and all that i go i told you not
to do it
and you went ahead and did it all right
i had to go mr blonde here
they had it done what i told them not to
do right
and she comes over i want you go hug me
would it make me feel better so i'm
hugging her
and she's like crying she goes dad you
broke my heart
it was like three gangsta movies that
was godfather too
she fredo'd me
i just told her i said listen we're
gonna play again we're just gonna do it
tomorrow night you just have to
understand that i'm not gonna sit here
picking up all these pieces as you're
acting like a crazy person
um you know
and i agree had agreed to play two games
that
and shoots and ladders right
and ac dc fans if you ever listen to sin
city bon scott during the breakdown
goes ladders and snakes
that is gill snakes take
i'm like i never really
thought about that i didn't know what it
was but that is as i learned on this
podcast
shoots and ladders down in australia
is called ladders and snakes
right but for whatever reason the toy
makers here are like oh we don't have
snakes and freak people out
and uh you know the snake was in the
garden of eden i'm sure with some
religious
[ __ ] weirdo reason you know
as we commit genocide and uh you know
have no problem with slavery
we can't have a snake on a child's
a child's board game right so they
changed it to shoots and ladders
a little ac dc trivia there uh which by
the way i found this great
bootleg of ac dc in 1978
wbcn the great rock station no longer
around but what a what a
station that was um they had
they went down and recorded ac dc live
at the paradise
which i don't know if that club still
exists it was this amazing rock club
like you two played their first
uh either us show or
um on their first tour they played the
first time they played boston they
played in the paradise
like the amount of bands the police u2
ac dc all these bands before they got
big that was the spot where they played
so there's this great
live recording um
because it's a radio recording it's it's
phenomenal
um
i was listening to that on some website
i just
you know where i wasn't eating [ __ ]
cake
like a fat [ __ ] bastard so
but um
what i did the other day because i'm
already turning the ship around was i
just decided i was looking all right you
know what
it's five o'clock i just had a little
dinner i'm done
until tomorrow and that when you do that
it's kind of hard the first night but it
kind of resets all your levels
and you're not chasing some sugar salt
[ __ ] that's causing you as you know you
know when you're in that bad eating
phase and as you're eating you're like
why am i eating this
i don't want to be doing this what the
[ __ ] am i doing and you're still just
shoving it down your throat
swallowing it whole like one of those
goddamn [ __ ] seagulls um
so uh yeah so i kind of broke that
but you know it's my son's first
birthday
and i have to make him a cake i just
have to that's my thing
because my wife was just like well you
know we got all this cake from these
other people's birthdays and
i was like honey this is my thing okay
no matter what i do okay i i have to
this is my thing
so they will say every year he made me
on my birthday my dad made me a homemade
cake
you know you got at some point you have
to have you got to build your brand
the uh i got you i love you
and despite you know me putting away the
board game and you saying you broke my
heart
the man makes me a cake so i know
where i stand with this guy you know
it's a it's a statement
um so i got to do that today uh
you know because i don't have time to do
it
on the old birthday there so um i gotta
knock it out today
all the flowers gonna be flying
so anyhoo um let's talk a little nhl
hockey let's talk about
the inverse of the nba playoffs
where you have competition these [ __ ]
nhl playoffs
have been amazing um right out of the
gate i have to give a shout out
to toronto maple leaf fans
okay and i'm gonna tell you nobody has
more heart
than toronto maple leaf fans
okay i can tell you right now if the
toronto maple if the montreal canadiens
did what the [ __ ] maple leafs
have done to their fan base over the
last 54 [ __ ] years
okay you would have no problem getting a
ticket in montreal and i can even say
that in boston you would have no problem
getting a ticket
you cannot get a ticket to a [ __ ]
leafs game you just cannot
i used to have hook hiccups on the nhl
radio
i had hookups in nh people who worked
for the nhl
and they were like not even we can get
tickets
you have to go scalp a ticket and you
know me and vergie's standing out there
the cold had to go scalp a [ __ ] tail
take it
or you might have gone through my buddy
bruce
of uh bruce hills just for laughs i
think we went through him
to try to get to somebody it was like
trying to get a sit down with a [ __ ]
mob boss
and the fact that you would think
that they were doing the inverse of what
they were doing
how hard it is to get a ticket and every
[ __ ] year
they get into the playoffs and there's
so many people going to the game there's
an
overflow of fans standing outside on a
grassy knoll
watching their leaves leafs
pushing them on trying to get them to
end whatever the [ __ ]
is going on up there and once again
the [ __ ] leafs
they blow a 3-1 lead
not only did they blow it they blowed it
they blew it to the [ __ ] montreal
canadiens
the most pompous arrogant ass fan base
you're ever gonna meet
it's they're like yankee fans and
they're french
it's just there's no talking to those
people
um
yeah they gave it up in their own end in
game five and game six in overtime i'm
gonna get through this quickly out of
respect for leaffence
and then they just didn't even show up
for game seven it's just un
unfucking forgive i don't know what the
[ __ ] was going on
um and they [ __ ] blew it again if
they beat the montreal canadiens i mean
that would that
in a lot of ways would have been as good
as a winning a cup
just to shut those [ __ ] arrogant
[ __ ] up
um i mean you're talking about fans that
are so [ __ ]
arrogant they booed patrick wah out of
the city
that's how arrogant they were because
they thought their next candle oh we'll
get another ken dryden we'll get another
patrick wah
we're gonna rock at richard we're the
[ __ ] canadian do you know who
we are yeah
1993 whatever 95 whenever the [ __ ] that
happened 94.
um it was 95 i think because i believe
patrick went and literally won this
first year out in colorado
i think like their fan base
was like an old celebrity
they were just completely out of touch
with where they were in
uh they were like a celebrity that made
it on their looks
[Music]
and they still thought that they were
the hottest [ __ ] chick in town and
they didn't realize that they were 20
years past their [ __ ] prime
i'm not quite 20 i'd say 15 or 16 that
the league had changed there was all of
these teams all of this competition
and their whole mystique that they were
just going to get put on the power play
at the end of every game if they were
down
um and their fan base could like
intimidate the refs into doing that [ __ ]
it just
was [ __ ] over and they didn't realize
it they didn't realize it
you know um it's like me when i watch
the nba that i don't realize that no
matter how much i complain that i am not
watching competition anymore
this is what it is now that if you want
to win a title
you know more times than not say three
out of five titles
or four to five titles that you're gonna
see every half decade are gonna be
purchased at this point um
you know i'll just say the bruin bruins
islanders uh series the first game was a
little lopsided but that game too was
[ __ ] amazing [ __ ] amazing and i
know it's amazing
because i aged like [ __ ] three years
watching it
and then when we lost in overtime i
literally was like
why do i care about sports that's how
much it [ __ ] hurt
so the exact
inverse when i'm watching my celtics
playing the brooklyn nets
i mean it was a joke other than that
what did we win game three other than
that game
it's like the game was over by the
second quarter
there was no drama there was like no
nothing and then what i love is the
[ __ ] idiots on these sports channels
have to keep selling the game to me like
i'm watching
competition going james harden had 18
assists last night oh my god it's just
like how
i could have had nine
all i needed to look up was a black
jersey i had like a
50 50 chance i was throwing to a hall of
famer i mean it was [ __ ]
it was [ __ ] ridiculous um
astoundingly boring and i have to tell
you
my team lost and it didn't even hurt it
was so [ __ ] stupid the whole thing
was so [ __ ] such a farce of
actual competition in an actual [ __ ]
game
um the nba has become like a bad summer
hollywood movie
well you know those movies where it's
just like oh you know you got the
superstar
celebrity you know they're not dying you
know whatever problem whatever gimmick
is going you know they're gonna solve it
you know in the end everybody's gonna be
[ __ ] safe
that's it maybe one person gets killed
in the movie and in the nba that's the
equivalent you blow out your achilles or
a [ __ ] acl
but in the end you know who's gonna win
you know who's gonna win so i don't know
why
the nba is the way it is
but it is the stupidest these stupid
[ __ ] pylon teams and i know i always
have to say this
the celtics had one in 2008 it's [ __ ]
stupid
these are not like
i don't i mean technically their
championships i don't know what
you know i don't know what to tell you
and and for some reason
fans say to me well the celtics did it
too and then i go
i know and that wasn't right and it's
like yeah but you guys did it too like
they don't give a [ __ ]
it's the weirdest thing that's like i
guess
nba fans like a rigged game
um it's a [ __ ] shame man um
because when you really look at if you
looked at the um
the oklahoma city uh thunder
is they drafted
you know they drafted those that those
big threes they drafted those guys oh
wait no yeah
yeah they did it because i'm saying wait
a minute they got kd from seattle i
forgot seattle moved
um so it's really the sonics
and the uh
thunder drafted that team that you know
back in the day
would have stayed together and i think
would have won a title
um and it said that whole team just
[ __ ] breaks up
and just piles on elsewhere trying to
make it work and then they all
reconvened
i mean i'm not saying it always [ __ ]
works but just because it doesn't always
work
doesn't mean it's good for the league i
don't uh and i know i'm just i'm
starting to sound like [ __ ] lenny
bruce here just reading my [ __ ]
trials
papers but um
that [ __ ] celtics uh
um brooklyn series
was the most boring thing i ever watched
even when we were winning that game and
and jason tatum
we won game three it was just like you
already knew it was it was over
they just had two it was just too many
[ __ ]
superstars on one team um
boring as [ __ ] is all i could tell you
national boring association um
all right let's [ __ ] plow ahead did i
talk about everything that i kind of had
to talk about oh let's talk a [ __ ]
winnipeg
jets versus the montreal canadiens so
you guys all know i [ __ ] hate the
canadians right not even the canadians
i mean i really like the franchise i
just can't stand their [ __ ]
fan base you know what i mean
they're like the socials in uh what was
that [ __ ] movie speaking of oklahoma
where they shot it um
oh my god i can't believe uh i [ __ ]
i'm thinking the wild bunch it's not
what it was called it was the cowboy
movie
the [ __ ] was the name of that movie he
had tom cruise
patrick swayze matt dillon
the oak ridge boys what the [ __ ] was the
name of that i don't [ __ ] know
um anyway plowing ahead
greece is in the socials this is gonna
diane lane this is gonna [ __ ] kill me
emilio estevez estevez
who else was in that movie uh ralph
macchio
leif garrett you can name the whole
[ __ ] cast
the outsiders there we go
yeah canadian fans they're like
dissociates in the movie the outsiders
so anyway i'm watching the pregame
yesterday of the canadians first the
winnipeg jets
and the guy in and everybody's telling
me yeah don't worry bill the winnipeg
jets they get a [ __ ]
they're going to mop the floor with
these canadians right and then i watch
the pregame
and the one of the analysis uh pregame
analysis guys goes
uh you know the montreal canadiens are a
pesky team
and i immediately cracked up like that
is not a [ __ ] compliment
hey geez you guys are sort of bothersome
um pesky annoying like some little kid
precocious kid talking and she's trying
to [ __ ] put together a toy or some
[ __ ]
so as a bruins fan oh i'm like oh good
so because i don't know anything about
the canadian teams
because i didn't see any of them this
year i was just sitting there watching
whatever [ __ ] division we were in
and i was like oh good pesky is good
pesky means they're not going to win
this series
and then the [ __ ] game starts and i
swear to god it was two nothing before
winnipeg
even knew that the second round had even
begun i mean the first goal was a good
goal that second goal
there was like two three guys standing
in front of the net just walked
watching the guy in the canadians walk
the puck in like you guys aren't gonna
do anything all right there you go right
there fred two nothing
[Laughter]
[Music]
then winnipeg's like oh i guess we
should start trying what do you think
fellas
you guys all warmed up it's two nothing
then they got a goal made it two to one
and then the canadians was at suzuki
came back with a sweet goal i don't know
what the [ __ ] goaltender was doing
the [ __ ] defenseman was playing the
[ __ ] pass
he just [ __ ] i don't know what
happened suzuki i mean it was a
two-on-one
but he should have played the puck
that's what i would have done in the
pickup league that i'm not in
and it was like 3-1 and then two seconds
later became 4-1 but they disallowed the
goal
and uh then that was it
that was [ __ ] it and your montreal
canadiens are now up
one game to none
and canadian fans are already chirping
going we want boston right they're
already giving me [ __ ] and it's just
like
yeah dude we're not afraid of you guys
we've had wonderful success against you
guys in the playoffs since the late 80s
once again the old [ __ ] celebrity
still thinking that they're the hot [ __ ]
on the block you you don't
have the mystique you used to have but
you still have the [ __ ] fans
and that's why i root so hard against
them it's not even about the
the [ __ ] abs um because once again
it gets to the point of like all right
if they win the cup what do i give a
[ __ ] we're like 90 cups behind it we're
never going to catch them it doesn't
[ __ ] matter
but what does matter what does matter to
me
is that they're coming up on 30 years of
no cup
um okay and they need tarantino right
now
to write a pulp fiction and give them
the john travolta part
so they can get out on the [ __ ] dance
floor one more time
that's what they're looking for so i'm
going to be watching that series
um i mean i don't know who's going to
put the canadians to bed i don't think
they have it this year so i'm not
worried about that [ __ ]
um and the bruins i say we got a
maybe a 50 50 chance i know a lot of
people hey dude you guys are gonna
[ __ ] be it's like well you know the
islanders are no slouch
um you know i've watched a little bit of
the avalanche they're [ __ ] terrifying
um tampa bay's the defending champion so
i would say that we
if i had to like the little that i've
seen because i just kind of watched
bruins games when i could this year
i feel like we're as far as chances of
winning it
as we are a distant third
um i think there's a there's a
a definite gap between what we got going
on in
tampa bay and then a bigger one with uh
with the avalanche who just seemed like
[ __ ] world beaters here
so um anyway that's my [ __ ]
nhl take and uh have fans i don't really
hate you as much as i say hey chad don't
give a [ __ ]
it's just fun to tease you um
because you are arrogant [ __ ] so
it's just fun to let you know
remind you every once in a while that
nobody gives a [ __ ] about
the [ __ ] 10 stanley cups you won when
they were still playing pond hockey
during world war one
you know i'm not going to be a douche
show you know from the 1940s on i mean i
respect all of that [ __ ] but you know
those other ones
the montreal canadiens beat the 23
skadoos
um you know and every sport has that
every sport has that all right um
anyway plowing ahead but every other
sport council but any
in the nfl doesn't jesus bill you're
gonna make bring up your same [ __ ]
nine sports arguments maybe i will
maybe i will it's my podcast um so
that's
it i i got a birthday coming up here so
i am going to drop a few pounds this
week that's my gift to myself
because i'm going to live my best life
she's living her best life
all right everybody it's policy genius
you know summer's quickly approaching
enjoy it without a looming to-do list
policy genius makes it easy to get life
insurance done
and done right and then you can go back
to slowly killing yourself at the
cookout right that's what you want to do
boozing it up feeling productive after
submitting your taxes
ride that wave and get your life
insurance done too with policy genius
it's easy and quick
policy gene just makes it easy to
compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all
in one place why compare you can save
fifty percent or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
you could save thirteen hundred dollars
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
the licensed experts at policy genius
work with you
they work for you sorry not the
insurance companies so you can trust
them
to help you navigate every step of the
shopping and buying process this is how
it works
getting started is easy first head to
policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
life insurance coverage you need and
compare personalized quotes to find your
best price
when you're ready to apply the policy
genius team will handle the paperwork
and scheduling
for free policy genius never sells your
information to other companies palsy
genius doesn't add on extra fees
head to policy genius now to get started
uh to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
okay oh look who it is everybody one of
my favorites simply
safe isn't that what we all want to feel
simply safe is an award-winning home
security system
so you know it's engineered with the
latest technologies you want to keep
your family safe
but that's but what really sets simply
safe apart is its people
highly trained security experts who are
always there for you
when you need them most these are people
who truly care about
uh keeping you safe when an alarm goes
off a person who cares is there for you
with the phone call to make sure you're
okay
when an emergency happens a person who
cares is there for you by getting fire
and police responders to your front door
right away even if you're just having
problems setting up your system
a person is there who cares to help you
set it up with a friendly
chat for any quick questions you have
the bottom line is when you need the
most simply safe is there 24 7 with
people who care and
and experts train uh to not only keep
you safe but to make you feel safe
it's one of the many reasons us news
recently called simply safe the best
home security of 2021
that's huge uh to learn more about how
simply safe can help protect you
and your family visit safe dot com slash
bird today
to customize your system and get a free
security system
uh you get a 60 day risk free trial so
there's nothing to lose that's simply
safe
s-i-m-p-l-i s-a-f-e
dot com slash b-u-r-r to customize your
simply safe system
and get a free security camera today
oh look who it is everybody oh
stamps.com
the old reliable okay are you still
going to the post office
why uh still paying full price for
postage
why well thanks to stamps.com
you don't have to anymore mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your own
computer
send letters ship packages and pay less
a lot less
with discounted rates from usps and ups
and more stamps.com saves businesses
thousands of hours
and tons of money every year you've
heard me talk about stamps.com they've
been sponsoring the show for over nine
years now and if you haven't tried it
what are you waiting for stamps.com
brings the services of the us postal
service
and ups right to your computer it's a
must-have for any business
whether you're a small business office
sending invoices a side hustle
etsy shop shipping out orders or just
navigating this hybrid work life
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
no wonder over one million businesses
choose
stamps.com for their mailing and
shipping not to mention stamps.com is a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder
nearly 1 million small businesses
already use stamps.com
stop wasting time go to the going to the
post office go to stamps.com instead
there's uh no risk there's no risk and
with my promo code burr
burr you get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus
free postage on a digital scale no
long-term con commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in bur
that's stamps.com promo codeburr
stamp.com
never go to the post office again you
know the way i look at montreal canadian
fans i bet a lot of people that work in
sweatshops
view everybody in my country like that
as we're walking around i'm living my
best life wearing all of this [ __ ]
somebody making 30 cents a [ __ ] month
oh jesus bill can you just stop bringing
up the woes of the world
all right sorry maybe i'm in a little
bad mood because you know i was trying
to be a good parent and then my kid
tells me that it broke her heart
um anyway
uh that is the deal um
i was going to bring something else up
but i don't want to do it because people
died
uh yeah let's not do that let's let's
let's wait a while i'll wait a while on
that one
i will wait a while on that one and i
can tell you i'm really into baseball
this year i don't know what it is
for some reason i think uh just because
i know my life's gonna get really busy
again i just love the pace of a baseball
game
or maybe because i'm [ __ ] old i don't
know what it is
but um i just really been getting into
it well
i will i in between periods i like go to
the mlb network or something i just find
a [ __ ] game
because i thought i had the mlb package
they keep they keep giving it you know
giving me free samples like a drug
dealer
and uh i don't know i don't know how to
[ __ ] order the thing over your phone
or whatever on the screen i try to do it
and i just [ __ ] it up every time
so i keep telling my wife can you do
this and she's like oh
god you know um so she
which is really [ __ ] up because i
started watching the real housewives
with her i just finally gave into it
it's like can you [ __ ] hook me up
here
you know would it would it would it
would it would it
kill you to come my way
just a little bit you know what the
worst thing is is she does like one
sport she likes hoop
and the nba which i still believe in i
believe they're gonna come out of this
stupid ridiculous period that they're in
right now
it you know at least when baseball was
in a bad
era there was like steroids you know so
you just watched these guys coming up
there like [ __ ] gorillas
i mean i didn't like the uh
those 200 million 190 million red sox
yankee teams
going back and forth winning i didn't
like that either i liked when we beat
them but i
you know the back of my head i mean how
excited could i be when we [ __ ] went
up against the colorado rockies
um take that man um
i did enjoy the steroid era
i don't know if that's a popular opinion
whatever i enjoyed
the hell out of sammy sosa and mark
maguire
smashing the ball over the [ __ ] fence
i enjoyed watching barry bonds do it
you know and to this day is it this is
just going to be all bill's old sports
arguments that nobody cares about
i will i said this [ __ ] 20 years ago
and i maintained it until today
barry bonds was a victim of the steroid
era i think everybody knew what was
going on but everyone was making money i
think even the press looked the other
way
right and barry bonds was the guy
and then everybody else cheated and then
they became the guy and next thing he
knew the president
was congratulating sosa and maguire
and then i think barry bonds was just
like
all right is this how the game's played
this
is me on steroids there's 73 mark
chip right
so i didn't have a problem with that and
then they did the usual they did the
tour de france thing
tour de france made all that money off
of [ __ ] lance armstrong and in the
end when they pretended like they were
disgusted
by the cheating in that [ __ ] sport
it's like the whole [ __ ] race
everybody tested positive everybody
tested positive
anyone who tested positive got [ __ ]
shamed by the sport
and then all those [ __ ] that ran it
kept all their money
didn't keep the writers money but i'm
saying all the money they made off of
those guys doing what the [ __ ] they were
doing
they kept all the [ __ ] i didn't see them
giving it back
when they were going after lance's money
and [ __ ] i didn't see the
the people that made money off of
landscaping yeah this was disgusting
this is dirty money
we need to give this to uh you know our
favorite cherry
they kept their [ __ ] money anyway
he's dirty he's dirty over here we're
[ __ ] clean
so i guess what i'm saying to you is i
am a
filthy sports fan that watched a lot of
[ __ ] bad [ __ ] go down and i enjoyed
it
all right i enjoyed watching the houston
astros
banging on that [ __ ] trash can
i enjoyed it i enjoyed i didn't even
know that a fan was someone that figured
it out now that's a hardcore [ __ ] fan
that
that person figured it out before mlb
figured it out
i [ __ ] enjoyed that
you know i really did i enjoyed that i
don't have a problem with anything the
patriots did
i feel a lot of that was just [ __ ]
trumped-up charges i mean come on
oh yeah all out of all the [ __ ] they
said what do you got us you got us
one game filming the opposing uh
coach was illegal game one of a regular
season
the [ __ ] out of here um
you know what else
what else did i enjoy i enjoyed every
cork bat
i love a cork bat i love a pitcher that
has like [ __ ] every condiment you i'd
loved phil necro and those guys gaylord
perry back in the day
i thought that [ __ ] was hilarious i
loved that guy in the yankees
who had the big [ __ ] the shiny
vaseline or whatever he had on the side
of his neck
i love that dude that had the [ __ ]
nail file
and he tried to do like i ain't got
nothing and it [ __ ] flew out
and that umpire saw it i love all of
that [ __ ]
um and i love the steroids era
however i draw the line
because to me that's all just nitpicky
horseshit
you know except for the you know i
didn't enjoy the uh
you know two teams with all the [ __ ]
money in baseball buying up all the free
agents
the same way i don't like it in the nba
that's my only [ __ ] thing but if
there's going to be somebody
occasionally coming up with like a cork
bat
or too much pine tar in their bat that
shit's funny
it's part of the [ __ ] game you know
there's holding on every play [ __ ]
whatever i don't give a [ __ ] and you
know and if guys are gonna come up
on steroids
okay and smash the ball through the back
of a [ __ ] dome stadium i mean i i
can't
i can't lie to you and say that that
that wasn't fun to watch dude i saw
[ __ ] mark mcguire take batting
practice
in 1998
down at the old ballpark was like
[ __ ] qualcomm whatever the hell it
was called
the the [ __ ] stadium was three
quarters full for his batting practice
and this guy put on a [ __ ] show
dude i felt like i was at rus
wrestlemania
watching this guy's hitting this guy
hitting [ __ ] lasers out there so
whatever if you guys want to call me a
hypocrite that i shouldn't did not come
down on the nba then goddammit guilty as
charged all right
that's the podcast i got hiccups again
[ __ ] eating bad go [ __ ] yourselves
and i will check in on you on thursday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
june 3rd 2013 in the year of our lord
yahweh jesus christ and friends
as we look at one another this week and
give thanks
ugh there's anything [ __ ] worse than
that long-winded
guy up there in his anderson little suit
you know that guy wasn't a priest but he
might as well have been
that flanders dude just coming up and
speaking reading the first two stories
the first reading is from the book of
corinthians
and i you know what i can't even [ __ ]
i can't even
i was just going to start doing some
dumb story and i i
so didn't listen in church i can't even
do it
i just remember just he does this from
the book of the corinthians
paul and john
like [ __ ] 10 minutes later and they
were just like something like this is
the word of the lord
thanks be to god how'd you like that
story cause i got another one
right and then he [ __ ] rips off
another one
and he just [ __ ] sitting there all
right all right what happens here
is there a leper is there a hooker
what's going on right and they get to
that one and uh praise be to the guy
with the thing
right and then the [ __ ] so that's
like you're you're
that he's like the opener and then the
priest comes down and we all got to
stand up because he's so [ __ ]
important right
and he says a couple of things
you know this is the gospel of the lord
and then i got to sit down and listen to
your [ __ ] take
on this god ah you blue you guys already
know how i feel
you know i feel
do you know how i feel sorry i'm all
over the place can you feel can you feel
the stress
i have to get this [ __ ] podcast done
and i have to immediately upload the
thing and i'm not gonna make it i got
something at 1 30 and of course i just
get a text message
did you get the email about the the new
location of the meeting
yeah it's going to be 60 miles further
in a county direction
as compared to where you're at i love
that [ __ ] did you get the email why
don't you [ __ ] call me
and just tell me i said you know what an
email
is it's like that's like a uh i don't
it's not whispering but it's it's a
secret
you're just leaving a note you know
somewhere in the vicinity of my [ __ ]
life
is it vicinity of vicinity i think it's
vicinity
does it start with a v or an f
oh bill can you okay there you go you
know something if you listen to the rest
of this podcast that was a legitimate
question for me
all right now if you listen to the rest
of this this is on you
okay because you could tap out right now
two minutes and 54 seconds in why are
the levels so high
i don't know bill cause you never got a
producer well that's probably why
that could be one reason um
all right let's get right out of the
gate and let's talk some nhl hockey
oh were those pittsburgh penguins fans
talking [ __ ] to me on twitter
not all of them hurry up and beat the
maple leaf so we can [ __ ] kick you in
the kind of the rangers whatever so we
can beat you up and all this [ __ ]
blah blah blah blah blah right
you know and i i'm and i told you guys i
i think the penguins are going to win
the series okay but these [ __ ]
jerk-off penguin fans
because they got all the [ __ ] pouty
lip eagle scout there they just think
they're gonna run over [ __ ] everybody
you know what pittsburgh relax you're
not winning the cup
you know why because i said so
cause i'm jealous of your [ __ ] team
that's why but i loved
game one i was i was actually working at
the borgata in
atlantic city hey they i had a great
time
um thank you to everybody showed up
except for that one guy
some angry guy in the back and just kept
anything i said he just in the beginning
he just kept [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] you know that i'm angry
at my dad [ __ ]
you know just yelling all this dumb [ __ ]
um other than that i had a great time
and um
so anyways i i missed some of the game
but i was going back and forth you know
running into the green room watching it
between shows and that type of [ __ ]
and uh or when the uh teen idol
sensation joe derosa was on stage i was
watching it and uh it was funny right
the beginning of the game
i see matt cook you know hitting
everybody with his stick and everything
and
i me i just get this sinking [ __ ]
feeling i'm like oh god
the guy he's literally a [ __ ] monster
i don't know why the dude is still in
the league it's just
it's unfucking believable and the second
you see the guy he's got oh god who's
who's he who's he gonna
whose career is he gonna try and end
tonight you know and especially with the
history that the bruins have with the
penguins
you know i told i told you all that [ __ ]
i respect the franchise the way they get
all these unbelievable
players but i just i don't know why they
have guys like that on their [ __ ]
team
and this is a sad thing about matt cook
that guy is a really good [ __ ] player
he just plays the [ __ ] game you could
you could make like
20 youtube videos five minutes long of
each different [ __ ] all right uh
shoulder to the [ __ ] head just five
minutes of those
his boarding ones that's probably like a
30 minute video
and then like the bonus like credits
extra when you have the bloopers would
be him checking that dude and
accidentally
severing his [ __ ] achilles tendon
which
everybody viewed as an accident but i
have to be honest with you i've been
watching hockey for 33 [ __ ] years
i've never seen anybody check somebody
into the boards
and accidentally sever the back their
[ __ ] achilles tendon
not even cut the back of their leg i've
never seen it
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know so he
goes out there takes him all of i don't
know what
15 minutes of the first period before he
sees somebody where he can see both
their numbers read their whole last name
and his street address and he just slams
[ __ ] mcquaid into the boards
and something unbelievable happened he
actually got kicked out of the [ __ ]
game
and i loved it i absolutely [ __ ]
loved it and i hope they continue doing
that
because it's a selfish way to play the
[ __ ] game
to just have no regard for the fact of
how hard somebody worked
to live their dream to play professional
hockey and you're out there and just and
i'll tell you guys like him
never get their knee blown out of sami
said none of those [ __ ] guys it never
happens to them
i don't know why and uh it's just
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] ridiculous and
other than that i don't have any problem
with the the penguins and if you're a
penguins fan right now and you're gonna
[ __ ] send me an email and go what
about what is it marshawn who [ __ ]
had the boarding call how come you only
got two minutes
it's like because he hasn't ended
people's careers marshawn has a terrible
[ __ ] reputation
and he got talked to and he also toned
down his game and you know
i that you know most of his [ __ ] is ken
lindsman type [ __ ] but like that thing
where people were coming to check him
and he would duck down and take their
legs out
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] move it was a
punk move and i didn't like that one
either and if you said that that guy is
a punk piece of [ __ ]
i'd understand why you did that i
wouldn't be sitting there you know
scratching my head in some dumbfounded
way but the amount of [ __ ] penguin
fans that sent me emails
like just like defending the [ __ ] guy
it's it's like i literally i get like
like it's like walking bikes when i see
matt cook it's like a rabid [ __ ] dog
you're like what's he gonna do this game
is he gonna gouge somebody's [ __ ] eye
out i i don't know
i don't know so i was psyched that they
immediately removed him from the game
um i don't think he should get suspended
but i understand why he got a gay
misconduct and i do believe that if
anybody else did it they just would have
got [ __ ] two minutes or whatever the
[ __ ] it is
maybe a major because he laid down on
the ice for a minute
um but you know
it's like that rasheed wallace thing by
the end of rasheed's career
if he stubbed his toe in the locker room
he already came out with the [ __ ]
technical
for cursing so um as much as i'm going
to enjoy this series i'm sitting on the
edge of my seat praying to god matt cook
doesn't end another [ __ ] bruins
career
um other than that i think it's going
seven i think it's gonna be an
unbelievable [ __ ] series i think the
penguins are gonna win tonight
um because that's how these things go
and then game three will obviously be
huge when they go up to the [ __ ] got
it uh what else what other hockey [ __ ] i
have not watched anything out in the
west but uh
i think the kings are uh really
overlooked even though they're down 02
that team scares the [ __ ] out of me just
because i watched how they won it last
year
and they seem like when you know when
they want to flip the switch
and also i wasn't too impressed with
chicago having a [ __ ] uh
3-1 lead and then all of a sudden you
know not being able to finish people off
so we'll see
we will see what happens that ought to
get me a bunch of emails
you know i'm actually doing a gig in
pittsburgh
and i would not be surprised if matt
cook if he here says shows up to my gig
with a hockey stick in full uniform
and uh severs my [ __ ] achilles
[Music]
um so there you go other than that was
[ __ ] great game i loved how
frustrated crosby got it was great
watching him slash whoever the [ __ ] he
slashes he was laying on the ice that
made me laugh
i was like that guy he's livid i wanted
to see his bottom lip start quivering
you know big pouty lip um all right
so i'm reading this story today uh
chinese city to find
unwed mothers the chinese city
they don't even say where it is or maybe
they do it i just can't read it
and they're gonna find unwed mothers
uh critics of a plan by wuhan
woo hand woo hand
wuhan clan ain't nothing to [ __ ] with uh
wuhan officials in who bell
uh province say a fine of up to 26 000
bucks will lead to more abandoned babies
i had a [ __ ] you a man and a baby
somebody flushed a baby down the [ __ ]
toilet i mean it's just the most
[ __ ] up thing it's so evil i don't i
can't even look at the story
they had to literally carve out the part
of the pipe
where they heard this thing criminal
this isn't even funny but like
jesus christ and you're sitting there
going that thing is so young
um hopefully it won't remember it but
god help that thing if it ever gets in a
crowded elevator one day i think that
that's when it's like
26 or something that's when it's gonna
snap all of a sudden
you know get away from me just stop
throwing [ __ ] elbows
i can't breathe um so listen to this
[ __ ] a chinese city
wu ham is planning to find women who
have children out of wedlock
a policy which opponents say will lead
to more abandoned children
um the plan drawn up by family planning
officials and woo
hand the capital of the hubel province
would target women who knowingly have
children out of wedlock as opposed to
what
unknowingly having a child you know you
hear it hit the floor like did somebody
hear something
what what was that sort of a squishy
sound
who is crying
sorry ah jesus these are baby jokes
people
baby jokes uh matt cook would cross
chuck a
check uh [ __ ] baby if he could read
its entire [ __ ] name on the back of
its little uh
it's a little scrunchy whatever the [ __ ]
you dress a baby in scrunchy
i don't [ __ ] know sorry i'm under the
gun here people i'm gonna stutter a lot
here because i'm looking at the clock as
i'm doing this here
like that guy you went on the foul line
with three seconds left and the game's
tied
look at old freckleface sweating out
there
hey red face you suck clank
can you just focus fundamentals rick
barry
hey you freckled kite your mother's over
click and it's over we go to overtime
and i get traded the next year um
chinese state media said the law would
help keep the birth rate low and aid
family by planning
by planning uh by family planning
management
the law was announced just days after a
newborn baby boy was rescued from a
sewage pipe
and i don't i can't even say what the
[ __ ] that is reports suggest that the uh
nia was i being that i was that loud
right
oh sorry [ __ ] we had the window open
just yelling you freckled [ __ ] i'm
yelling basketball [ __ ]
she just tippy-toed in and closed the
window by the way my neighbors
hate me they really hate me despite the
fact that i'm the i'm the kind of guy
i'm the type of guy like ello cool j
says that if there's
litter outside even on my street
if some [ __ ] throws a [ __ ] beer
bottle and there's glass in the street
i go into my house grab a broom dustpan
and a [ __ ] garbage bag and i'll walk
a full block down the street and clean
it up just so my neighbors don't get
flat tires
alright now i ask you this
does that balance out screaming you
freckled [ __ ]
at 11 47 in the morning on a monday
main odds are everybody's at work people
next door selling their house
you know i had to listen to them with
their kids out at their pool yesterday
that [ __ ] you know
that's good sweetheart mommy mommy all
that [ __ ] ugh
yeah bill but at the end of the day
they're not yelling freckled [ __ ]
i guess freckled isn't bad it's probably
the [ __ ] part
you know is that a hyphenated word can
you guys teach me how to spell this week
all right so anyways do you know why
there's so many [ __ ] people in china
because there's no continent i guess the
uh their leader over there
told everybody to uh
to just have as many kids as possible so
they've become this powerful nation just
out of the simple fact of having so many
[ __ ] soldiers all right so now what
do they got over there well
how many billions of [ __ ] people over
there do they have
well bill why didn't you look it up
before you did the goddamn podcast
instead of uh you know asking us about
it
population of china here we go this is
going to be a real half-assed podcast
this week
everybody so why don't you if you're
sitting there in your cubicle they have
1.344
billion
[ __ ] people
jesus christ
oh my god can you [ __ ] imagine that
india has 1.2 india's creeping up on him
holy [ __ ] can you imagine being a
comedian in
india how many [ __ ] twitter followers
do you have if you're like the [ __ ] i
don't know
the kevin hart of [ __ ] india you must
have
[Music]
you just have a 100 billion [ __ ]
twitter followers
100 million sorry this is insane the
united states is
third 315 million
unbelievable thank god for nuclear
weapons huh no wonder we don't want
anybody else to have them
it's the only thing that's keeping us in
power at this point
go ahead and [ __ ] with us russia only
has 143 million
that's unreal they got all those [ __ ]
guys in the nhl we got to step up our
game
where the hell's canada you know what
this might actually make me like where
i'm going
germany has 80 000 [ __ ] people that's
because your country's the size of the
size of like a state
how does ethiopia have more they're
[ __ ] starving they've got 86
86 million germany has 80.
sitting over there with their little
shorts on drinking beer all october
it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
okay let's get there i want to live you
know something i want to live in a
[ __ ] country that has like nobody
let's get all the way down to it let's
get down to the lowest populated one
there we go the k
piccairn p-i-t-c-a-i-r-n
islands has 66 people that's that's too
little
that's too little that's where you got
like a beard down to your [ __ ] legs
all right i don't [ __ ] know so
anyways they're charging these [ __ ]
who is over there every time they have a
goddamn big
[ __ ] basically get charged [ __ ] are
like uh you know
skanks get charged 26 grand which i
guess is like three times what they make
a year
that's [ __ ] unbelievable
can you imagine trying to pass this law
over here with all these goddamn jesus
freaks
how much they would freak out i'm
actually i'm trying to look at this this
type of uh
this type of news more so than uh
you know all the american [ __ ] that i
get over here i'm on this [ __ ] al
jazeer [ __ ]
i know right now all americans hear al
jazeera they think terrorism
because the only time we ever see al
jazeera is when they show [ __ ] those
sawn people's heads off videos but
they're actually like uh
i don't know what they are like a
regular news just for over there so it's
kind of [ __ ] interesting to see their
view of it i'm not saying i agree with
it
all right a week after [ __ ] memorial
day before you start [ __ ] coming down
on me
but anyways back to the podcast uh i
want to thank everybody who came out to
my shows in red bank
uh in uh baltimore eastern pennsylvania
and
atlantic city i was touring with the
teen idol sensation
from the opiate anthony program uh joe
derosa
and uh jesus christ we had a [ __ ]
great time
i rented a car and we just drove from
city to city and uh
i don't think we had one serious
conversation the entire time
just sitting there laughing our [ __ ]
asses off at one point we were driving
from baltimore
to uh where the hell were we going up up
to eastern pennsylvania and for once we
weren't hungover i think that was the
one night we weren't really drinking
and uh halfway up there i just started
singing hair metal songs
about what an awful comedian joe derosa
was
and i got into the third song before i
realized that he wasn't enjoying it as
much as i was
i think was during the bon jovi living
on a prayer
i got to the chorus oh i was going joe
he's halfway there
joe right just i was thinking about what
a hack he was
and i saw a look of pain on his face
that was beyond
you're a terrible singer and i was like
uh joe am i bugging you
he goes uh yeah a little bit kind of uh
kind of bugging me there
um but i think i have to take a month
off from boozing after that one
we were eastern pennsylvania and by the
way a town that everybody [ __ ] made
fun of
then i was going there like why aren't
you going to philly i'm actually going
to philly
but uh it's not going to be until later
on this year
and eastern pennsylvania was
unbelievable
[ __ ] beautiful town it was a little
sketchy but they're on the upswing
because i was sitting there looking at
it i saw this one guy
crossing the street neck tattoo crossing
the street diagonally you know that punk
move
[ __ ] traffic that guy and the second i
saw that guy me and derosa were eating
these sandwiches
and i'm looking out the window taken in
the town and i see this guy crossing the
street
slowly diagonally with this neck tattoo
you know not looking clean not looking
dirty
it's the middle of the [ __ ] day on a
weekday doesn't have a job
and i said that guy right there joe that
guy alone
i would not buy a house in this area
just the fact
that that guy every time i go into town
to get
my provisions the fact that that
[ __ ]
is going to be crossing the street
diagonally
with this stupid i'm a badass neck
tattoo and i'm not saying he couldn't
kick the [ __ ] out of me i'm sure he
could but that that's the type of [ __ ]
all right you want to sell me a house
you want me to move to your neighborhood
you get rid of all these people [ __ ]
crossing the street diagonally
all right you cross the street in the
crosswalk or if you're jaywalking
you have you have a sense of urgency and
courtesy
that you're being a bit of a [ __ ] right
and this guy wasn't so right there i was
like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
so i'm hanging with deroza right so
every time we go to we got to go to
these [ __ ] comic book shops
whether you see star wars posters is
that an original print
and there's literally some tub of [ __ ]
actually only one show
one one [ __ ] giant guy was working
they're just a stereotypical one
the one we went to we went to um kevin
smith's
that secret stash one out in uh red bank
new jersey and that place was the [ __ ]
i'm not even gonna lie to you this was
tremendous it was everything most comic
book stores aren't
and i'm judging them just by
going to them with deroza it was clean
it smelled alright
you know they had some decent
memorabilia and that type of [ __ ] i
don't even mind comic books it's just
like
just every story is like 70 years into
it so i can't jump in anywhere
but i really like the drawings and all
that type of stuff you know having super
powers and some hot chick you're [ __ ]
banging she has no idea about your other
life
and she thinks you're cheating on her
but you're actually saving the world i
mean
what what is not to like you know
and uh but we went to this one in
[ __ ] eastern pennsylvania and then we
went like two doors down and there was
another one
we came walking in there we started
talking to them about the town and they
actually said it was on the upswing
you know i looked at their little center
in town where they had a little gazebo
or some [ __ ] and i guess back in the day
people were openly doing drugs there
so uh they've turned the corner and we
performed at the uh the state theater in
eastern pennsylvania and it was
just a [ __ ] awesome show and then
afterwards
we go out to get some mexican dinner and
i [ __ ] said i was going to give these
people a shout out
god damn it where the hell is my phone i
actually had some mexican food that
could [ __ ] with the mexican food out
here in la
you know and that's saying it was
definitely more i guess of americanized
sort of uh food network kind of thing
where they uh
you know they switched it up a little
bit but we came in right before they
closed
and they were just like uh you know
they recognized joe derosa you know i'll
tell you he has that leaf garrett fame
it's called mesa modern mexican that's
what it was
they did that [ __ ] with like listen the
chef's just gonna uh cook up some stuff
made this unbelievable burrito had this
other thing with this [ __ ] shrimp and
it was unbelievable
that i say unbelievable enough times
well i don't give a [ __ ] right
so then we go around the corner and we
end up drinking in this romanian guy
this guy from romania
a romanian guy drinking his bar and they
were literally giving us
chalices of [ __ ] jameson
and i owe them an unbelievable tip
because i don't i was so [ __ ]
hammered
when i left there that i don't remember
tipping
and you know somebody's hooking you up
with drinks you should be [ __ ] you
know
laying down the [ __ ] uh andrew
jackson's there and i wasn't so uh
that's that's that's on my list of [ __ ]
that i have to do today i have to find
out who the two bartenders were and i
have to tip them out because i forgot to
because i can only imagine the stories
they're telling about me right now but
like
they literally we sat down and they gave
us like two [ __ ] goblets
now it looked like a red wine glass no
somewhere between a red wine glass and
that [ __ ] chalice of beer that they
used in the miller like commercials back
in the day
um and like that wasn't enough
the owner comes in this romanian dude
he's [ __ ] right and he starts
lining up shots and you know
i'm saying oh you're from romania oh
that's cool man what's romania like he's
like it's a piece of [ __ ] country
and i'm like nah come on man that's not
it's a piece of [ __ ] did that [ __ ]
get to pieces he just kept saying it's a
piece of [ __ ] country and i'm like okay
so it's a little corrupt but the
uh the scenery there mountains some
trees that you missed that piece of [ __ ]
i appreciate you coming down here you
don't have to be it's a piece of [ __ ]
country just kept saying
this country was a piece of [ __ ]
um which i haven't even been there and i
still disagree
i disagree i bet the people in power
have made it a piece of [ __ ] country
uh but you know come on you can't tell
me there's not some beautiful things
there some beautiful women
you know there's got to be some [ __ ]
rock band over there that you like
the romanian ravens or something i don't
[ __ ] know
so anyway so we go there we had a great
time there and then we go down to
[ __ ] atlantic city
and uh ran into chris porter down there
[ __ ] hanging out with tim we just it
was just awesome man when i got to watch
the bruins
beat the penguins in this [ __ ] brutal
series that we're gonna have so i want
to thank everybody who came out to all
those shows
i'll get back to those things in a
minute here i got to read a little bit
of a little bit of advertising everybody
listen
no [ __ ] as far as i know
it's gonna be uh father's day is coming
up
as far as i remember what the [ __ ] is
this
ah christ why why can't why can't i do
this right
can i ever do it right is this it there
we go everybody okay let's start again
ladies and gentlemen father's day is
coming up it's coming up this sunday
you got to get the old man a gift he was
nice enough to have unprotected sex with
your mom
god knows when and now you're here all
right
so here you go you got to hook the old
man up uh this father's day think the
man great what is demand great you ask
or maybe you thought it or maybe you
mumbled it um there are 100
they are 100 made in america cast iron
grilling grates that are revolutionizing
the way people grill
heavy-duty grill grates deliver exactly
what you need to achieve that perfect
steakhouse flavor chicken steak or
veggies
will never have tasted so good no more
flare-ups
no more dry meat it's guaranteed name
one of 2012's best grilling
accessories by men's health magazine man
greats are the perfect gift
for dad this father's day so how do you
get it well you go to man great.com
and you enter you enter the coupon code
burr b-u-r-r
for their father's day special
or click the man great banner on the
show website i gotta be honest with you
i don't know how they're only 20 bucks
they actually gave me some they're
awesome and you could do curls with
these things
okay it's like a kettlebell you flatten
it out and you turn it into something
you can put on your grill
all right did i paint enough of a
picture 100 percent
made in america cast iron steakhouse
quality grilling in your backyard
remember each monday morning podcast
order comes
with a heavy duty grilling brush again
man great grill enhancement system order
today man great dot com
man great dot com enter the coupon code
bur and check out
alright so there you go so you hooked
him up with the grill
here's another thing for you you can do
this for yourself or for the old man
or maybe a hairy woman in your life the
dollar
shave club all right being a good
getting a good shave can be a real pain
in the ash
what are you shaving your ass that's
weird but that's weird to say that
in this copy because we're talking about
faces here and also you bring up an ass
and people have hairy asses
but you know what i i plow ahead
searching through 50 brands
of blades matching new blades to old
handles all the [ __ ] features when
your rage
razor doubles as a flashlight vibrator
toothpick all that stuff right
20 bucks for new razors and it is
[ __ ] you go into cvs and they have
them locked behind like their
bars of gold all right and you get them
in their little plastic hunks of crap
so would you like to play pay the right
amount of money go to dollarshave.com to
get high quality raises delivered right
to your door for just a couple of bucks
a month
they've made it simple high quality
razors 100
guaranteed set on set on a schedule so
you never even have to think about it
again
all right just shave your damn face and
you're like oh my god
i'm down to my last one knock at the
door here's some more
all right every month you get a new pack
and every week you change your blade
and it costs a fraction of what you pay
retail and you don't have to stand in
line
um if you want to try it uh go to
dollarshave.club
forward slash wait dollarshaveclub.com
sorry forward slash
burr b-u-r-r you'll get a free sample of
dr carvey's
easy shave butter um with your first
shipment
also makes the perfect father's day gift
dollar shave club something you can
actually use
all righty and the last one here in this
chunk i believe
i believe i can fly
um hulu plus you've tried streaming hit
shows on your pc on hulu.com now it's
time to start your free trial of
exclusive content
in your living room and on your mobile
devices on hulu plus
with hulu plus you get total control to
watch thousands of shows
uh wherever you want whenever you want
use hulu plus on connected tvs
game consoles blu-ray players roku
apple tv pc or watch anywhere on your
smartphone or tablet
on demand all the time this is why i'm
getting this right now because i'm
always on the road
and i can watch my hockey playoffs right
on my phone
and with hulu plus you can binge on full
seasons
watch your classic favorite or current
shows and even full series runs on
classic tvs it's endless once again for
you people who fly on planes
this is absolutely perfect you don't
have to pay for their bs
wi-fi and all that crap or do you maybe
you do to get to it
i don't know it'll help you heat up a
flight hey bill why don't you stick to
the copy
all right i will they've got community
modern family south park
snl monday night raw the man show jimmy
kimmel family guy and more
feel free to swap out with um the show
list with some stuff that you like to
watch bill well i never look at the show
list i'm sorry
hulu plus is only 79 7.99 per month
but right now they're offering an
extended free trial of hulu plus that is
available on
for podcast listeners only take control
your tv experience go to
the podcast page at billboard.com click
on the hulu plus banner
for your extended free trial or go to
huluplus.com
click the hulu banner on the podcast
page billboard.com
or go to huluplus.com all right there we
go there we go
back to the podcast everybody um
all right where are we in this podcast
right now 31 minutes in well god damn it
i think it's time to hear from the
listeners
all right you've listened to me run my
mouth enough haven't you
oh wait i forgot to mention when i went
to that um
where the hell were we oh in red bank
new jersey
they have a baseball trading card shop
there
uh that's another one i took a picture
of
let me see if i can find it here on my
phone it was [ __ ] unreal man they had
these old
nba cards they they were giant
um oversized ones that i had never seen
before
and uh i kind of went nuts when i went
in there
i ordered uh i didn't order i went and i
bought
like a dr j a pistol pete a cream abdul
jabba
there it is um
monmouth m-o-n-m-o-u-t-h
stamp and coin shop vintage sports cards
and all that and red bank new jersey
um they have some unbel they have
unbelievable collection of cards and all
that type of stuff
and um you know it's really cool man
it's just one of those old school places
you take out a credit card and they pull
out like that
that credit card scan thing that they
had back in the 70s you know when you
bought gas and stuff
um but it's phenomenal and of course i
got those and now i'm like obsessed like
i have to get the entire set
and then i want to get a bunch of
[ __ ] baseball i mean
basketball and hockey cards from the 70s
and i had to shut down my ocd but
i definitely went out and i bought uh i
bought a bunch
and i found a frank old frank tarkington
card when he was on the
the giants that type of [ __ ] and
everything so
anyways let's plow ahead here um all
right
casino floors i mentioned this the other
day
once again when i went to uh i was
working the borgata
um and they just had i should have taken
a picture of the rug
it's like absolutely [ __ ] insane so
here's here's some more uh
theories on why casino floor rugs
are so crazy all right he says hey bilbo
i'm from australia
and i'm used to emailing you letting you
know i've been carpet laying
what oh and i'm just
you forgot the j dude i thought you were
writing like some sort of
uh shorthand there i'm used to i just
i'm just emailing you
letting you know i've been carpet laying
for two years now
and the carpet you're talking about is
just a commercial carpet and it is
surprisingly
expensive it is around a thousand to
three thousand dollars a meter a meter
little more than a yard
for all you americans um which is 3.66
wide parenthesis 12 foot
i don't [ __ ] know and one meter long
all right we don't we don't lay carpet
we know we know it's expensive here we
go
times that by getting like 600 meters to
do a casino floor these carpets
last forever you can put pianos in poker
machines and whatever you want
and they never leave indentation see
this is it this is why i love the
[ __ ] podcast
after all these theories of dude people
puke and piss you can't see it
you drop your chips you can't find them
uh what was another one um it's so zany
you don't want to look at it so you just
keep looking at the machines
here's a guy who's actually laying
carpet
or works for the casino and is now
claiming he lays carpet to get us off
the scent but i i like this this
actually makes sense
um he said these carpets last on all
capitals forever
you can put pianos poker machines and
whatever you want and they never leave
an indentation
they are easy to maintain and clean they
are usually made in england by either
x minster carpets or wilton carpets
the patterns are always outrageous but
it's for commercial places like casinos
and banks
and even train and bus seats oh that's
right yeah when you get on a train a bus
they have those [ __ ] horrific looking
those things actually gross me out
because it doesn't look like they clean
them at all um
i like the all plastic all plastic seems
like germs can't get in there as
well um so there you go everybody that's
from somebody who actually lays the
carpet there
and we're not just talking about us sex
life
um wife's family the secret upstairs all
right
hey bill love the podcast and all the
[ __ ] so i've been dating this
lady who i completely love can't get
enough of her
we've been going out for a solid two
years now good for you
um there has always been a rule at her
house
she lives with her parents because she's
in a program in order to become
a vet tech so money is tight for her
that i am not allowed to go upstairs
ever all right being a guy i have no
problem with this
uh i'll bend her over the pool table and
her jesus christ dude
this this took a left turn i'll bend her
over the pool table her father built
because
[ __ ] it if you try to stop me from
banging her in the bed i'll just find
another way
all right dude what what did that have
to do
with what you're talking about you got
me all
interested in why can't you go upstairs
like there's this big mystery now all of
a sudden you're like well fine i'll bend
her over the
[ __ ] hot water heater downstairs you
can't stop me
all right i'm hoping you're gonna get
back on track here that was like a weird
uh b story um he goes so i finally get
annoyed at this whole no upstairs policy
and decide to do a little investigating
well aren't you just a nosy little [ __ ]
did you finally get annoyed
of the rules of a house that isn't yours
you know what sir so this far into your
email i don't like you
i don't like that whole [ __ ] with you
you haven't you're disrespecting her
father and saying i'm gonna [ __ ] your
daughter
over the pool table that you built all
right
that's supposed to be internal monologue
you're not supposed to share that with
others
anyways uh no one in the house at this
point by the way
oh there's no one in the house why can't
you guys help me out you know i suck at
reading
okay there's no one in the house at this
point by the way
i work third shift so they leave me the
[ __ ] alone between 8 a.m to 3 p.m
i went upstage upstairs and i find uh
garbage in the hallway every room is
filled with junk
and there's only one way to enter it
this is every room
her parents room hers the office it's
all
a complete nightmare just waiting for
tlc to show up
um now giving you that how can i
approach
this ordeal with her i love her to death
and she may be moving in with me
sometime between the next few months
this [ __ ] is not going to fly with me
but i know that if a resident gets that
bad
that there is something wrong with them
mentally she has always been messy but
then again i'm a [ __ ] cop who doesn't
have time to clean up my place so maybe
this
is the calm before the storm with this
chick
um yeah that's really [ __ ] up now
all right well you know something you
already broke the seal this is what i
would do
this is so [ __ ] creepy
if you if you really want to make a go
with this girl
i guess i
i guess i would go back up there again
and i go into her room and just have a
look around
and look like if that's some parent [ __ ]
or if that's her [ __ ]
you know what i mean um
and if it's her [ __ ] i would be uh
ah geez this is [ __ ] brutal the thing
you know what the big thing is
is the fact that the downstairs is
immaculate
so they're they're they're only halfway
down the rabbit hole
um i don't know dude you know what this
is your tree you're [ __ ] sitting in
it i don't th there's no way to bring up
that you went upstairs without just
saying
i went upstairs what are you gonna say
well the bath the tor this is what yes
is what you do
this is what you do you clog up the
bathroom downstairs
all right just clog up the [ __ ]
toilet downstairs
i don't know how you do it but just clog
that [ __ ] up
okay and then just say i had to take a
[ __ ]
i there was nowhere else to go i i had
to do it right
and then you just say you went upstairs
saw what the [ __ ] it was and then you
went back downstairs all right
so that's what you do clog up the toilet
and just blame it on the fact that you
had to take your [ __ ]
why am i helping you with this lie
that's funny to me who gives a [ __ ]
there you go and that's what you do
and then address it all right
or you just man up and just say listen
all right
the curiosity this is this is the man's
way of doing it that's that's the [ __ ]
way of doing it so of course i know how
to do that way
the man just sits down and says listen
all right
it was [ __ ] weirding me out that i
could never go upstairs
i just went to the top of stairs and i
looked see what the [ __ ] big deal was
you know like was it made out of gold do
you got a sex slave up there
you know there's some dead body what the
[ __ ] going on up there and uh yeah
that type of [ __ ] you know that's your
world that's your life but uh
that's not gonna happen if we ever move
in together
all right and then she's going to give i
can't believe
that you went upstairs when i told you
not to you just broken the trust and
you'd be like all right and let it just
do it let it get all of that out and
then you go
wait a minute wait a minute what about
you okay
so i just broke the trust but you know
you're the one you kind of you had this
giant
secret so you got secrets so
you kind of [ __ ] with the trust first
you know
do you know there's a dead cat up there
do you understand that there's a [ __ ]
dead cat up there
so i don't know do do one thing or
another you can do the [ __ ] thing and
do the toilet clogged up thing i gave
you two options there sir
the [ __ ] [ __ ] way or just be a [ __ ]
man
just take her out sit it down just say
listen i gotta i gotta tell you
something
all right uh i feel ashamed that i did
this but my curiosity got the best of me
and i went to the top of stairs and i
just peeked to see what the big deal was
with the upstairs
uh and you know then she'll probably
start running away but you know women
they don't know how to run most of them
women can either run like a [ __ ]
track star or they just re they run like
it's
they run like toddlers
you know so many of them i swear to god
i'm not saying you don't see the
an uncoordinated guy jogging every once
in a while but you know we play sports
we know how to run
you guys i don't know what you do you
sit around plotting and
making [ __ ] rumors about each other
jesus bill well you know what it took a
while this week didn't it
43 minutes in before i said some
ignorant [ __ ] about women i'm getting
better
i had to get a nice clean half hour
there
um so when she runs away from you like
uh you know somebody blew out her knee
you know just sort of jog behind her
until she gets tired
um or just wait till she's wearing high
heels until you tell her that that gives
you an even better chance
you know and as she's scrim screaming
and boo-hooing and crying and all that
you know you just walk behind her with
your hands out you know looking at other
people like you know
you know you you do that classic you
know this isn't my fault [ __ ]
that that body language to other people
which is basically you put your hands
you know basically parallel to your
shoulders straight out like that
you know like you're going to shrug like
you know i don't know you have it like
that
and then after you do that then you
bring them together in front of you
motioning at her you know like yeah you
bring her back out again
she's just ah and i don't know yeah
right just back and forth
and then you just say well you know
something and as much as she gives you
[ __ ] just be like you know what i'm glad
i looked
i'm glad i looked because if i didn't
look i wouldn't you know we got to talk
about this i'm willing to help you
through this and everything but i can
tell you right now if you think you're
gonna move in with me
and start doing that stuff uh there's
gonna be a mountain of [ __ ] getting
thrown out every [ __ ] week
all right so there you go sir
that is my advice that is my advice
to your [ __ ] ass good luck to you all
right
moving off this rock aloha you [ __ ]
uh spent 35 of my 42 years stuck on
these collections of rocks
and here we go once again with the
spelling [ __ ] no to you all
known to you all as the state of hawaii
and can't wait to get the [ __ ] out yes
it's a great place to visit
don't get get me wrong hell anywhere is
a cool place to visit
but live here but live there a while and
the daily [ __ ] that affects
everyone builds work life
it starts to grind on you even more so
when [ __ ] is ridiculously
even more so when [ __ ] is ridiculously
expensive
this okay this isn't me people for once
this isn't me uh you know what
i'm just gonna read exactly what this
guy wrote for the rest of the time and
you can see what i deal with every week
all right well you know some of it is my
ignorance all right i'll take 80
of it but 20 percent of it is this [ __ ]
all right let's go back to that last
sentence
hell anywhere is cool to visit but live
there a while and the daily [ __ ] that
affects
everyone bill's work [ __ ] life
starts to grind on you even more so when
[ __ ] is ridiculously expensive
all right that's a sentence everybody i
must sound like an uppercase
[ __ ] for complaining about paradise but
trust me the only things that
that's that's come out of hawaii
that's even halfway decent our bj pen
and pineapples and bruno mars
and jimmy superfly snooker
is he from the isle of samoa uh bj
hasn't been great in a while and even
the pineapples they sell here come from
costa rica or someplace like that
another thing when the best comic to
come
over and do a show is mike epps do i
need to say more dude mike epps is
[ __ ] phenomenal have you seen his
latest special
he's unbelievable and not to mention i
did a show over there you [ __ ]
well yeah mike epps is better than me
maybe that's what he's saying jesus
what's it gonna take to impress you
anyways he goes phoenix arizona is where
i'm headed to open a business so i can't
wait to see some actually
actual talented comedians well i hope
you're not hawaiian if you move into
arizona
because they'll probably try to send you
back to mexico those [ __ ] maniacs
um netflix and watching a new special
can only take you so far you know anyway
don't think i
ever heard you read an email from hawaii
on your podcast so it's worth a shot
take care and go [ __ ] yourself listen i
can see
um i can see myself moving there and
after a while going out of my mind
because i have to move around you know
and just
living in that little last state out
there i would just uh
yeah i would go nuts i need to uh i need
to be on the mainland i
i definitely couldn't handle that and uh
good luck to you sir if you want to move
uh
away from there and plus you know what
you're not moving that far away
it's like this i guess everywhere is far
away from hawaii
because it's like a five-hour flight i
don't know dude listen man i don't know
what the question was
if you want to [ __ ] move out go ahead
and move out but uh
everybody needs to watch my cap's latest
special man it's [ __ ] unbelievable
um all right and i wish i i
read that email first i wouldn't have
said his name because i hate when people
do that [ __ ] cause then it's like i'm
co-signing on it i'm not trashing that
guy on any [ __ ] level
all right billionaire [ __ ] hello bill i
recently met a
very beautiful young lady who was an
heiress
to a greek shipping magnet
uh and worth billions of dollars jesus
christ how do you
where the [ __ ] did you meet her huh
french riviera wouldn't let me guess she
went into hooters right
um she's actually quite beautiful and is
nice until she gets a little booze in
her
then she turns into a super [ __ ] like
i've never seen
uh i am really into greek girls and
she's extremely hot and if i could just
deal with her bitchiness
then i would never have to work again
however i have way too much pride and
after starting
after she started bossing me around
at it at a sunset boulevard bar the
other night
i just took off when she went to the
bathroom
and have not returned to her i have not
returned her what happened calls
dude you just left
why did you do that i totally resp
respect leaving but you should all right
let me just read the rest of this and
i'll finish this
and once again with the [ __ ] spelling
errors and leaving out words
she was calling me and texting me and
emailing me
as i walked home down laurel as pissed
at what as i was at the time the thought
of never
knowing what happened is actually funny
now
uh dude you don't love this girl if you
think that shit's funny you don't love
this girl
he goes i don't i don't know her that
well but i see that crazy look in her
eye
know that she has never been told no in
her life my instinct is a hundred
percent to never respond to her
and not return and not turn into her
[ __ ]
uh what do you do bill a leader of the
degenerates
um
i think it's [ __ ] hilarious that you
left but i think um
it's still funny that you just left if
she's that hot and that rich if you just
[ __ ] left
and never returned her phone calls that
that's definitely funny
but that's also psychotic that's
something that i would [ __ ] do
um you probably should have hung around
uh and said something
just say listen uh this evening's over i
just really don't like you as a person
and uh you're beautiful and but um i i
would never want to spend my life with
someone like you all right
so i haven't have a nice evening i'm out
of here right
that's what you could have done you
could have done that right
i miss my [ __ ] meeting here god
[ __ ] damn it
um that's what i would do sir i totally
respect the fact that you left but next
time you should probably just say
something to her i did that one time you
know i actually did that one time
i [ __ ] went out to uh went on a date
with this girl we went to some go see
some [ __ ] band that only played
80s music i think they were called the
m80s it was out in santa monica the
first time i lived out here
and this girl [ __ ] jumped up i was
with all of a sudden she jumped up on
stage with the band and started doing
this douchey dance
and was pointing at the crowd and
it's like i wasn't on a date anymore all
of a sudden i was at like a concert like
i didn't know what the [ __ ] happened
and i was just like uh
i just left
[Laughter]
and the reason why i left was
i didn't know how to say that really
just turned me off and that was just
really [ __ ] weirded me out like
like the band didn't want her on stage
she went up there and they're looking at
it like who is this [ __ ] idiot up on
stage with us
and i i just didn't know how to i didn't
know how to do it back then
you know nowadays if i was still [ __ ]
dating i just would have been like oh
yeah you know you just really seem to uh
have a good time duh all right
i'm out of here whoa what's the matter
what's going on i think you're a great
person but i'm not feeling uh that
second date
all right why is it because of what i
wore
no it's because of that [ __ ] stupid
dance whatever the [ __ ] you just did up
there all right gave me deuce chills
okay i'm sorry
goodbye
you